[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right men all Tata please be seated
if I could audio ku4 on my money
Martin Tama why they were talking me
under here upon on foot among I hated to
pull I the final money corpang getting a
car or a twerp or how poor port to the
victims brings families to our who did
he like Tahu Mart our water turns
directly to you the families who have
suffered who remain weeping mourning for
their husbands sons and wives daughters
grandchildren and our custom we allocate
a time for our people to grieve and to
sit with the spirit of the dead to
release their pain we have a saying
tears avenge death but we also
understand that there is a world where
pain no longer exists where the soul
dies where it is numb and Beyond feeling
and we call this world to call it the
world of nothing so does the task of our
woman who you hear keening to call to
you and to call to you to bring you back
into the world of light which we have
now to call you back to the world of
both pain and joy because these feelings
make us human
so commence your return back to tell
madam the world of light nor dieter far
am i part of my
how damn I know my hooking might return
to the treasures that we share as the
people the enchantment of human love our
fellowship and goodwill because these
are the treasures that the people of
Christchurch and New Zealand ask you to
return to return to this world for your
happiness the happiness of your loved
ones relatives and friends because our
compassion as a nation and as a people
in Christchurch today signifies
humankind
noreda Kyoto TR Ohio meter anna maria
caitanya tartar cart or Europe
korto querido my Tartu Kumar we are
Akita Tonetta called tato
tato yati FICA te we those who have gone
may you finally rest in peace we who
remain love and compassion to each and
every one of us care for the people T
hey Marie ora assalam alaikum peace be
upon you prime minister
your Excellencies heads of state members
of the diplomatic corps and all the
dignitaries who have traveled here I
stand alongside Knight aho and manaphy
Noah to greet you all and to welcome you
to Auto tahi our city of Christchurch to
those who watch from afar welcome you
are one with us today to all the people
of Christchurch including our elected
members and local leaders and especially
our Muslim brothers and sisters we come
together again as one as we have done
every day in our hearts and minds since
the 15th of March 2019 I started my
welcome with an acknowledgement to those
people who were taken from us on that
day I offer sympathy on behalf of the
people of Christchurch to all the
families who grieve you do not grieve
alone we grieve with you what happened
here in our city on that day which was a
cowardly attack on our Muslim
communities and their places of worship
at their time of prayer was also an
attack on us all on our shared values
and on our way of life inspired as it
was by hatred those actions were
designed to divide us and tear us apart
they have instead United us as we are
embraced in the compassion
and the love that we feel for each other
no matter where we were born no matter
how we express our faith we thank
everyone who has sent a message a
tribute a flower a poem a picture
children from across the country have
shared there are aha and such special
and poignant ways and the city leaders
across the globe who have stood
shoulder-to-shoulder with their
communities and all their rich diversity
expressing the same solidarity that we
can feel here today thank you for
sharing our grief and thank you for
helping restore our faith and humanity I
ask that today we collectively express
our gratitude and thanks to all those
who played such an extraordinary role in
our city in response to what has
occurred we think our first responders
including the New Zealand Police st.
John ambulance services and members of
the community at the mosques on the day
and passes by we honor those who went
above and beyond the call of duty we
thank all of the hospital staff who work
tirelessly to save lives and who have
offered care to those who were injured
and their families we acknowledge the
dedication of the coroner's City Council
City care and funeral director teams
along with members of the wider New
Zealand Muslim community who all work
together to ensure the families could
bury their loved ones with dignity and
respect we honor the Imams for their
inspiring leadership and for inviting us
to attend their call to prayer we honor
the Muslim community leadership group
for their dedication and we thank all
those who have provided cultural advice
and ensured decision-making has had the
community at its heart we will continue
to work together as one we acknowledge
and thank the Prime Minister and the New
Zealand government for all the
court they have wrapped around our city
and thank them for taking urgent action
to strengthen New Zealand's gun laws and
we call upon the social media platforms
to take even more responsibility for
ensuring that such as atrocities cannot
be live-streamed and that messages of
hate that fuel attacks on members of any
community cannot be shared hate has no
place here hate has no place anywhere I
have witnessed people across the city
and within the building where I work
drop everything and commit every ounce
of their being to supporting the
response and setting up for the recovery
we know from our experience that placing
the community at the heart of all that
we do ensures that our purpose and
direction will be true that is why I'm
comfort comfort n't that we will get
through this time and emerge a kinder
and more compassionate place something
we wish for the world however first we
each have a responsibility to ask the
hard questions of ourselves about what
comfort any of us might give to people
who Harbor racist or extremist views we
now know where this can end we need to
look in the mirror be honest about who
we are and gin and we must all pledge to
being a city of inclusion that genuinely
embraces diversity every day Otto
tae-hee Christchurch is a city of peace
we are a city committed to honoring
human rights we need to make this real
and we can help lead the way we will not
be defined by what happened on the 15th
of March 2019 we are defined by what
followed the unity the love the
compassion and the kindness they are who
we are nothing will come between us no
one stands alone we stand together we
are one quart a toad
so nor data at na koto tenor koto ten
artichoke art or
- all night - a good idiot a lotta my
day coca - all night - a Houdini
technical - yokutoku you worship the
Honorable and our mayor of Christchurch
thank you for your inspirational words
of welcome in your opening address
- Karina Cordero a yahoo DD Carty door
mata nui o Tahu potiki Dawei alpha upon
Akito not super now ladies and gentlemen
here to perform the renowned song of
Tahu potiki as a relish to the speeches
of welcome from Knights hoo-hoo-dilly my
Tahu in the beautiful city of
Christchurch
please welcome this descendant of the
who portugee from night Oh Marlon
Williams
[Applause]
Paul Tiki
[Music]
ah
[Music]
okey
[Music]
Otto hi
[Music]
Quixote
car honking
Oh
our Tokina
we
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
hi
[Music]
Oh
Karthik aaaaah
[Music]
mama people are
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr. Malucci audio do my talking Marlon
Dinard we're accompanied by auntie Aloha
Anton Ramona auntie Utica aunt elysian
auntie Hinata
Denmark
in a weaker cockier okay to hide in to
commence wanaka of today's remember in
service to deliver the Muslim and
vocation the doer would you please
welcome Latif Allah be the imam of
Lynwood mosque in Tehran ochita they
don't wanna need another
[Applause]
Salam alaikum peace be upon everyone
Kiara
I'll be learning Mina shape on your
warning
this
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
there are no food in the world I think
in hobby
[Music]
the Lord already says o mankind indeed
we have created you from male and female
imaginations and tribes that you may
know one another
indeed the most noble of you in the set
of Allah the God Almighty is the one is
the most righteous of you indeed Lord
Almighty is knowing and acquainted thank
you
yonni - okonomiyaki anafi ow
oh he domino toda Heaney ladies and
gentlemen
next speaker with words of introduction
is Chaka Khan president of the Muslim
Association of Canterbury Attalla
Martina graph at the 110 our menu in the
name of Allah the most gracious and the
most merciful brothers and sisters in
humanity
I gave him with the greetings of the
heart assalamualaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh peace be upon you all
on behalf of the local Muslim community
in Christchurch I stand before you today
with the mixture of feelings I feel
deeply saddened I am saddened that when
I look for them I can no longer see the
beautiful faces of the fifty men and
women and children that live among us
only 14 days ago
and although our eyes shed tears and our
hearts moon
we know that they are at peace I feel
incredibly humble I am humbled by the
outpouring of grief you all have shared
with us that you did not leave us alone
with our sadness but instead open your
hearts and it stood beside us
I feel immensely grateful I am so very
thankful that we live in a country like
New Zealand which are responded in a way
that none of us will ever forget that
let the world know who we really are
I feel ultimately hopeful
I feel ultimately hopeful I have a hope
that we as a community as people as
nation are now sure about the path we
want to walk the values that hold us
together and the spirit that - all two
weeks ago on 15th of March a terrible
act of dark rest happen but I asked us
all to consider this from this head how
much love has been shared from this
callousness how much compassion has been
shown from this despair how much hope
has sprung and out of this darkness how
much light has been spread Salaam
aleikum wa rahmatullah wa barakatu
peace be upon all of us
adela Matty - Afghani there now where
our next speaker ladies and gentlemen is
one of the survivors of the attacks on
15 March 2019
at the Al Noor mosque on Deans air here
in Christchurch
a truly remarkable humble noble and
forgiving men quater forgotten anata wa
bokura no way money who taught Aquino
Kotaro ha in the most tragic of
circumstances he has encouraged us all
to lived by the maxim if someone does
bad to you - good
in return please welcome ladies and
gentlemen mr. Fareed Achmed
[Applause]
al hamdulillah huben alam ii was fella
to us an average emir in the mba even
more easily all the things and praise to
the Lord of the universe may peace in
mercy be upon all the messengers and
prophets of Allah such as Adam Noah
Abraham Isaac Jacob Moses Jesus and
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon all of
them and Allah has mercy be upon all of
them his main man you are he I'm
beginning in the name of Allah the kind
the merciful one at Apple only menu
portal oofy feasible
hee hee
well kill Natasha Allah says in the
Quran do not say about those who are
killed in the service of Allah in the
worship of Allah they are dead but no
they are living their soul is alive
voilá kill Natasha rule but you do not
perceive it we believe that people die
in the good cause the people who were
killed in their worship they are in
paradise
their body is going to be perished but
their soul are not going to be perished
the souls are in paradise they are being
hospitalized by Allah merciful we also
believe that people who survived with
injury or the families who are going
through struggles for their patients
Allah is going to reward them and today
in front of all of us I would like to
offer my sincere prayers for the people
who have been killed and also people who
are survived I would also like to offer
my prayer to the new zealanders to the
new zealand for safety and security and
also i would like to offer my prayer for
the people in this world
for peace and happiness honorable
audience I would like to thank Anakin
acknowledge your presence today I'd also
like to thank the organizers to allow me
to speak in this auspicious memorial
service I also like to thank New
Zealanders for coming together to show
the world that New Zealand is a peaceful
country and it is going to be peaceful
inshallah people asked me that why do
you or why did you forgive someone who
has killed your loved wife beloved wife
the answer to this is I can give so many
answers but because of the time I'll
give only couple of points the first
point is I have a fate I believe in
Allah and Allah says that if we forgive
one another then he loves me he loves us
in holy for analysis he smiliar oh man
you Rahim one kerza me
Tina Louise one happy now I mean
well cuz we mean Allah ie the one Feeny
NASA's Cassini those who control their
anger and pardon they our fellow human
Allah loves those who are good doers so
I forgive and Muslim forgive because
they are taught by Allah they are
brought by firaon that if they forgive
then Allah will love them I'll give one
more reason I follow a prophet a
Messenger of God like all other
Messenger of God all other messengers of
Allah that he is titled maternal al-amin
mercy for the world Allah says about him
in me all my messenger I have send you
as a mercy for the wall without
forgiveness without showing mercy I
cannot be a true follower of him also I
don't want a heavy heart that is boiling
like a volcano a volcano has anger fury
range it doesn't have peace
it has head shaped it burns itself
within and also it burns the surrounding
I don't want to have a heart like this
and I believe no unders I want a heart
that will be full of love and care and
full of mercy and will forgive lemony
because this heart doesn't want any more
lives to anymores life's to be lost
this heart doesn't like that the pain I
have gone through that any human being
should go should go through that kind of
pain that's why I have chosen peace I
have chosen love and I have forgiven all
so people ask me that how come you are
still saying that you love him as a
human brother the answer to this is our
brother imam has recited the verse from
the philosopher arm it says this mean
man you roar him yeah
I um
Oh mankind in Zachary we have created
you from a single pair of male and
female referring to our original part
father Adam and mother II so we all are
Adams children Eve's children we are one
single family we are human brothers and
sisters how can I hate my human brother
I don't agree with what he has done I
don't support what he has done probably
he has misunderstood the whole thing
probably he had gone through some
suffering in his life some traumatic
thing happened to him and he could not
process well his suffering into the
constructive way that's why I don't
support his wrong action but at the same
time I cannot deny the fact that he is
my human brother each human being is my
brother is my sister this is my faith
and this is what Allah has taught me
that's why I do not paint him and I
cannot hate him I cannot hate anyone
and then
and then again I would like to say a
couple of words for the humanity we all
want peace we say that we want peace but
we were to start from somewhere we have
to start cleaning our own heart first we
have to change our attitude if our heart
is full of love then peace will start
from here and each one of us us has
responsibility from wherever we are we
have responsibility at least to start
from our heart and the second thing is
we have to change our attitude our
attitude should be we human being are
one feminine regardless of faith
religion culture and language I would
like to conclude with my beautiful city
where I am
this is crushed our city called Garden
City and in the garden we see beautiful
flowers and we have to learn from it in
the garden we see different different
types of flowers they are different but
together they make a garden they make a
beautiful garden they stay one beside
another with peaceful coexistence even
though they have they have difference we
human being has to be like this I may be
from one culture you may come from
another culture I may have one thing you
may want read but together
we are a beautiful garden may Allah
guide us towards the peace may Allah
guide new zealand safety and security
and may allah make new zealand peaceful
and may allah make the whole world
peaceful mean assalamu alaikum wa
rahmatullahi verified
funny eat our paper awhile alaikum
Salaam
then our way our hungry Yahweh now any
speaker ladies and gentlemen has worked
tirelessly since the events of two weeks
ago for the Muslim community here in
Christchurch for the Muslim community
across on Tarawa New Zealand and with
the Muslim community overseas he uttered
one word then ran out across the world
at last week's call for prayer Aloha
Aloha Aloha and he has proclaimed to the
world that we of New Zealand are one
graphical [ __ ] kurta he thought though
that though that aware please welcome
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the Federation of Islamic associations
of Altair or New Zealand dr. Mustapha
Faruk
[Applause]
in lyon rahmani raheem in the name of
god the most beneficent the most
merciful
assalamu alaikum peace be upon you
Karara port-au-patois
we are gathered here because of on 15th
March 2019 50 innocent Muslim
worshippers who are murdered by a
horrific act of terrorism on behalf of
New Zealand Muslim community we wish to
say a sincere thank you to all New
Zealanders for the compassion openness
and support you have shown us at this
very trying time no words can express
our gratitude for your kind words your
flowers your tears and one embraces the
Solidarity of our Kela family will
forever be in our hearts I would also
like to thank our New Zealand Muslim
community who at this time adhere to the
teachings of Islam as aptly described by
our broader foreign our met together
with our prime minister you have shown
the world how to lead with compassion
the world continues to watch al an how
we as a nation have responded as we pass
beyond the initial shock and grief we
ask that as a nation we hold on to our
solidarity and never let it go today is
a moment to reflect on the immense loss
that we have suffered but it is also
symbolic of how we wish to go forward
let's continue to build a future of
togetherness
and connectedness for everyone that
calls New Zealand home and for Humanity
I will leave you with the same words I
said in Tarot Maori here one week ago
Aloha Aloha Aloha here for capitai tato
Jonnie at the week of acoma halacha riot
article 10 i didö Ingham hypo I would
see detainee eToro week equally yogi we
now come to the reading of the names of
those who lost their lives through this
terrible act of Darkness undertaken on
15 March 2019 the names will be read
with the support of the Muslim community
interfaith society and will be read by
Ahmed Mohamed sir Achmed omar abu he's
Lee
you
ah [ __ ] America Tata
tsurara corner him I'm Emily deen
mohammed of the running the same I had
nine Youssef of a quick Costner Armond
say it realignment for Hirsch awesome
Merson mohamed el harvey ashraf ali
resent ashraf ali said jehan de Italia
for seeing a longer
Linda Susan Armstrong Musa lon Holly
Zechariah for hire Tramell Mohammad
Karmal Mohammad Kemal Dervis Atta
Mohamed Atta area Ali Mohammed Abdullah
al-madani
Amjad chasm Hameed lilyc Abdul Hameed
Muhammad Muhammad hot as a father and
see Ali Baba muhammad imran fan Alaric
turcica her own Mahmoud sayad Ahmed
Mohamed Nasheed Mohamed Mohamed Hadid
Muhammad Ali Hussain muhammad khaleel
mustafa [ __ ] muhammad the wouldna be
Torah proceed Omar Musa Valley Suleiman
Patel Abdel Fattah parson Mattioli Safi
Muhammad Abdul Samad
Mohammed Suhail shade
Manu Solomon Kali ma [ __ ] al-hajj
Mustafa Hamza
khaled al Hajj Mustafa Ghulam Hussain
Karen BB Muhammad position Reza name
Rasheeda told her name
Arif Batra and Ramez Laura thank you
Abdelkader Elmi mohammed omar farooq
mu'adh Arden Ibrahim Jeanette is my
bismillah ar-rahman ar-rahim Mohammad
Sohail Shahid uni Girgis free man Khalid
Norfolk al hajj Mustafa
Hamza Khalid Al Haig Mustafa bounnam
Hussain Quran Quran bebe Muhammad Ershad
Raza
Naeem Russian tell her name and our if
wara Ramiz herbivory now ladies and
gentlemen please remain standing for the
invocation detour from Sheikh Muhammad
Amir mufti of our WA new zealand a TV or
a 10 hour
salam-o-alaikum may peace be upon all of
you bismillah al rahman al rahim allah
wa anta salamanca Salam alayka Salam
Halabi Salam Salam Tabarrok turban what
are elated angelicum oh Allah we ask you
to guide us to the doing of good deeds
and abstaining from bad deeds and
forgive us and show mercy to us o Allah
we seek forgiveness o Allah we seek
refuge in you against the difficulties
calamities troubles and operation who
Allah grant us increase and not decrease
owner and not dishonor give us your
favors and do not deprive us well grant
us the best of outcomes in all our
affairs and save us from disgrace in
this world and from the punishment in
the hereafter oh allah have mercy upon
us all oh allah have mercy upon those
who were massacred two weeks ago who
Allah grant him the highest level of
paradise oh allah grant the injured a
speedy recovery and a grant the families
of the victims patients and healing oh
allah grant mercy to all those who have
extended their support at this difficult
time and reward them abundantly oh allah
grant us a life of piety and abstinence
and a guidance all to the straight path
oh allah grant our country or teruah
new zealand peace security and a
protected and its people from all people
oh Allah
the entire world peace security and a
prosperity did God defend our free land
God defend New Zealand
I mean Rasul Allah who wa sallim ala
nabina muhammad while he was serving me
Sheikh Muhammad Amir thank you very much
can a whole normal TV please be seated
ladies and gentlemen our next guest has
come a long long way to be here with us
today here now Abu Dharr Imam or to
Hagley Park in Christchurch at this hour
Nash new national remembrance service
Cortado dato a we are one joined on
stage by his very close kiwi friend on
base bruce Lynch ladies and gentlemen
would you please make welcome Yusuf
Islam ken Stevens
[Applause]
Salaam alaikum peace be with you
our hearts go out to the families of
those whose lives were snatched away in
that evil carnage while they were
worshiping in the mosque two weeks two
weeks ago we learn about things through
their opposites and it's through
opposites like this the evilness of that
act and what drove it we find its
opposite which is the love and kindness
and unity which has sprung up right here
in New Zealand and that love and unity
is actually what all the prophets and
messengers of the divine taught the last
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
that all of the prophets are brothers
their mothers are different but the
religion is one and I think that's the
message which a lot of people who have
professed faith should come back to
because there is the center and our
prayers go
to those shining souls who whose lives
were snatched away in that moment of
madness may peace be upon them peace in
this world may take a bit longer I'm
gonna sing a song for you now
[Applause]
[Music]
how long how long has this piece
training tell me how long
came to the station with a hole inside
hoping to see that nice train tell me
how long
[Music]
I've been crying lately thinking about
the world as it is
I've been crying lately thinking about
the world as it is why must we call 18
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been happy lately thinking about
the good things to come
believe it could be something good has
begun why I've been smiling lady
dreaming about the worlds Wow
believe it could be someday it's gonna
come cuz out on the edge of darkness
there rides a peace train OB stream to
this country come take me home again
beside been smiling lately thinking
about the good things to come
[Music]
nice nice train
[Music]
the restraint
[Music]
come on B string
your bags together
bring your girlfriend's to cozzens get a
mirror and soon we'll be with you let's
come and join the living
it's not so far from you
[Music]
soon it will all be - Oh peace train
[Music]
please train
everyone telephone be stayin
all these dirty
[Music]
crying lately thinking about the world
as it is
why must we go long 18 but can't we live
without all the
there lies a B strain strain take this
country
[Music]
these strange sounding
[Music]
come on these two
[Music]
thank you
a little bit more grace and time just to
do one more perhaps this is really a
song which could be said to reflect that
wisdom that when it's only when good
people stay sitting
that evil Rises so we've seen the
opposite in this country may God bless
you all
[Music]
don't be shy just let your feelings roll
on by
don't wear fear but nobody will know
you're there
just lift your head and let you feel
he's out instead
don't be shy just let your feelings old
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
thank you
that was awesome place Jimin please end
the wars yourself Islam has students
yeah and a covergirl market are talking
are awarded all at the favicon Okita
caught the Queen ladies and gentlemen
now to introduce her excellency Dame
Betsy really the governor-general of New
Zealand with her juries at the karma not
sayonara authoritative Kulina calc way
the tamari could have came out with an
Amana ue ni e be maha enough honor Mori
who tena koutou katoa hydra mitotic
ottawa kia Rebecca I to Khufu [ __ ] ahora
assalamu alikum I come here today to
convey love and messages of condolence
and support from our queen from leaders
of nations around the world and from our
fellow New Zealanders to the widowed to
the fatherless and motherless to the
injured to the bereaved families to our
Muslim communities and to the people of
Christchurch
although the depths of your grief and
sorrow is unimaginable we all shared
tears for your pain and your loss as we
all search for a way forward from their
grief history reminds us of what can
happen if good people stand by and allow
evil to flourish we are at such a point
in our history our best weapons against
the senseless and vile politics of hate
are to be found within each and every
one of us we face a renewed moral
challenge to do what we can to foster an
inclusive sense of community we all are
treated with
decency and respect communities where
people do not suffer discrimination
because of where they come from the
agenda their language the clothes they
wear or their religious beliefs
communities where our cultural
differences are considered part of
everyday life and are seen as something
to be celebrated with tolerance kindness
respect and understanding we can and
will defeat poisonous malice that seeks
to divide us but only if we also have
the courage to acknowledge and to call
out discrimination and racism wherever
we see it silence is not enough it
condones the thinking that can encourage
everything from casual acts of racism to
acts of violence when more of us stand
up to confront lazy assumptions
prejudice and willful ignorance the
easier it will be to drive away such
unacceptable behavior in the last
fortnight New Zealanders have responded
to this challenge we have seen a new
determination to stem the tide of hate
along with acts of great courage and
humanity this was evident and the
extraordinary courage shown by
worshippers bystanders and first
responders at the Elnora in Lynwood
mosques it was evident in the tireless
efforts of the medical staff who cared
for the wounded and it's been there in
the manake Tonga and Aroha expressed by
our citizens all around the country
in this terrible time of grief we have
been brought closer together
we have affirmed values that are so
important to us
tolerance kindness and compassion by
keeping that faith we can honor the
memory of those who lost their lives we
can support the survivors on the long
road to recovery and we can all seek to
ensure that evil does not take root in
flourish in our midst
again I will finish with the [ __ ] Toki
Amaury proverb heigh-ho Matthau Cato Kia
tequila
Marte arohanui car Ora
Oh No a cold wind chills us love and
goodwill restores us kira kia kaha
kiamana Whanui we frittata Ottawa
vikarma nuts here not your excellency
thank you
and now ladies and gentlemen introducing
the right honourable Jacinda return
prime minister of antair or new zealand
at the premier denmark where i up with
the world
you know rangatira mom
you know they are
you know Munna
Deena goes over
ah gusano Tina koto epic okay Joanna not
a ohm Omaha Kiran oh oh oh oh - time
hurry my taro a meteor a meteor Ana Mari
kita fanon a yomaira TI Onorato your
Amar'e ion Oh turtle Couture we gather
here 14 days on from our darkest of
hours the days that have followed the
terrorist attack on the 15th of March we
have often found ourselves without words
what words adequately express the pain
and suffering of 50 men woman and
children lost and so many injured
what words capture the anguish of our
Muslim community being the target of
hatred and violence
what words express the grief of a city
that has already known so much pain I
thought they were none and then I came
here and was met with the simple
greeting assalamu alaikum peace be upon
you
they were simple words repeated by
community leaders who witnessed the loss
of their friends and loved ones simple
words whispered by the injured from
their hospital beds simple words spoken
by the bereaved and everyone I met who
has been affected by this attack i Salam
alaikum peace be upon you they were
words spoken by a community who in the
face of hate and violence had every
right to express anger but instead open
their doors for all of us to grieve with
them and so we say to those who have
lost the most we may not have always had
the words we may have left flowers
perform the haka sang songs all simply
embraced but even when we had no words
we still heard yours and they have left
us humbled and they have left us United
over the past two weeks we've heard the
stories of those impacted by this
terrorist attack those stories of
bravery there were stories of those who
were born here grew up here or who had
made New Zealand their home who had
sought refuge or sought a better life
for themselves or their families these
stories they now form part of our
collective memories they will remain
with us forever
they are us but with that memory comes a
responsibility a responsibility to be
the place that we wish to be a place
that is diverse that is welcoming that
is kind and compassionate those values
represent the very best of us but even
the ugliest of viruses can exist in
places they are not welcome racism
exists but it is not welcome here
an assault on the freedom of any one of
us suppress who practices their faith or
religion is not welcome here violence
and extremism in
forms is not welcome here and over the
last two weeks we have shown that you
have shown that in your actions from the
thousands at vigils to the ninety five
year old man who took four buses to
attend a rally because he couldn't sleep
from the sadness of seeing the hurt and
suffering of others our challenge now is
to make the very best of us a daily
reality because we are not immune to the
viruses of hate of fear of other we
never heaven but we can be the nation
that discovers the cure and so do each
of us as we go from here we have work to
do
but do not leave the job of combating
hate to the government alone we each
hold the power in our words and in our
actions and our daily acts of kindness
let that be the legacy of the 15th of
March to be the nation we believe
ourselves to be to the global community
who have joined us today who reached out
to embrace New Zealand and our Muslim
community to all of those who have
gathered here with us we say thank you
and we also asked at the condemnation of
violence and terrorism turns now to a
collective response the world has been
stuck in a vicious cycle of extremism
breeding extremism and it must end
we cannot confront
we cannot confront these issues alone
none of us can but the answer to them
lies and a simple concept that is not
bound by domestic borders that isn't
based on ethnicity power base or even
forms of governance the answer lies in
our humanity but for now we will
remember those who have left this place
we will remember the first responders
who gave so much of themselves to save
others we will remember the tears of our
nation and the new resolve we have
formed and we remember that ours is a
home that does not and cannot claim
perfection but we can strive to be true
to the words and bedded in our national
anthem men of every Creed and race
gather here before they face asking me
to bless this place God defend our free
land from dissension envy hate and
corruption guard our state make our
country good and Great God defend New
Zealand cor Tata Tata assalam alycome
[Applause]